Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner, so I want to share
a video on understanding emotions role and cancer. And we could say emotions role
in any disease and this could be a series of 100 hours of videos taught by people that are a lot
smarter than I am. But I want to touch on some things because I think this is a piece that
we fail to investigate in ourselves because I think if we are honest with ourselves sometimes
we don't want to or we're fearful of really getting honest with ourselves. So when we look at
causes for cancer, causes for diseases, one of the things that we tend to shine away from
is dealing with this emotional piece. Some people are better at it, some people are
better at being open and understanding that maybe my breast cancer is tied to a bad relationship
that I had in the past or maybe my breast cancer or my liver cancer is tied to some anger that I
have held inside me. And then some people are afraid to deal with that and think that they might
have to go through years of counseling to deal with that. Sometimes that might be necessary.
But we have to address this piece of what emotions do to us and that they can be at least
to participate in peace in any disease. So let's just touch on that and I'm going to give some
examples to help us understand that. Organs can be tied to different emotions. There's many different
philosophies out there, some Chinese philosophies that ties a specific organ to emotions. It's been well
known that anger tends to weaken the liver and liver problems can be stemmed from from hidden
or bottled up anger. Fear affects the kidney stress weakens the brain in heart anxiety and grief
affects the lungs worry could affect the stomach. We could go on and on and there's many different
examples that we can think of with this. But the real tie to this has to do with how our brain
processes events. So as events are experienced, they are held in the brain in our memory centers.
And we're just beginning from a neurological standpoint to understand the importance of the
temporal lobe in holding long-term memories at a deep part of the archaeocortex called the amygdala
that holds its belief to be their very emotionally tied memories. So memories that have a strong
emotion tied to them. Maybe when we were abused as a child or when we went through a physical abuse
or a rape or emotional scar that we had, those emotions can be held in that deep part of the
brain called the amygdala that can be end up coming out later in life as a knee jerk response to
different things. And we don't understand why we respond that way, but it has to do with a past
event in our life. This is where post-traumatic stress disorder comes from. And it's held in there
where you see a soldier that was in battle years ago still responds to fireworks in a negative way
because that fear response is held in the amygdala and it fires off with anything similar. We'll
will re-enact that event in their memory centers subconsciously. So it is maybe an lesser degree in
so many things in our life and it's best if we can address those, especially if we're dealing with a
disease or a cancer or something. We need to start asking some tougher questions. There's many different
techniques out there. What is this technique called any t-dural emotional technique? And this is a
sheet, I'm sorry, it's not very clear on the slide here of some different emotions that are tied
to different organs. The stomach, spleen and the pancreas here are interconnected. A person with
stomach issues could have any of these motions that are tied to the stomach. And there's many more.
This is just this technique. And this is a very simple mind version of this. But let's say I have a
stomach cancer. Is it because I am overly sympathetic? Is it because I'm wholly disgusted emotionally?
Is it because I have an expanded importance of self? Is it because I have some obsessive,
compulsive ideas in my life? Is it because I have some egotistic issues, narcissistic issues?
Many of these you'll notice are opposite from one another. So despair may be totally different
than obsession or egotistic or narcissistic, nervousness, stifled, live life through others, overly
concerned hopelessness, lack of control over events, worried, distrust, low self-esteem,
very opposite things here. So a person could have an event take place in their life that
then has shaped their future decisions. And if that is a deep seeded in our mental structure,
it can affect that organ. In no way shape or form, are we saying anybody with stomach cancer has
to have these emotions? And we'll go over that and understanding that. We can use charts like this
to help us understand our emotions. But I think there's even a better way to look at our organs
and emotions. And that is to understand the physiology of each organ. So that's my first step
in this is to understand the general function of an affected organ. We could go back to a chart like
this and use the stomach. Well, what does the stomach do? The stomach holds things that you have
ingested. Well, think of that from a physiological standpoint. Emotions that are ingested
are similar to food that's ingested. And if we're holding on to emotions that are ingested
and they're not going past that to be digested and to be absorbed and to be dealt with and to be
broken out and to be changed into something that's useful and we're holding it in our stomach,
it's going to cause stomach problems. So if I'm dealing with a physical stomach problem,
we could understand that from an emotional standpoint, am I unable to process different emotions?
And because I'm unable to process different emotions, maybe because of the childhood experience,
then I could end up with stomach problems. Same thing with the pancreas. Understand the physiology
of the pancreas. What does the pancreas do? The pancreas makes insulin in order to to utilize sugar
and to utilize good things in my life. If I'm unable to process good things in my life and I see things
through a cloudy lens, quite often I could end up with pancreatic problems.
Pancreas also makes digestive enzymes, so it's part of the whole digestive and large intestine
example. I'll give you an example of a person that I know who has a large intestine issues. Well,
one of that that guy's issue with large intestine is he had to start facing some things that he was
he was unable to because of past events in his life to basically discharge waste is that what the
larger intestine does. So the larger intestine holds a discharges waste. And if you can't get rid of
waste in your life because of some religious point of view that was put in your life that you have to
be the good person all the time and you could never you could never call maybe someone in your life
bad or you could you can't make a judgment and say that this person in my life is not good for me.
So then I have to keep everybody in my life and I don't want to be the bad person and I don't want
to get rid of that person in my life because oh my goodness God forbid that would not be holy.
Then you're going to be more prone to intestinal problems, large and small intestine,
pancreatic, same kind of thing that's supposed to be making digestive enzymes to break down waste and
help get rid of it and help utilize that. But when we come from a spiritual perspective or I should
say a religious perspective that we can't make judgments in our life and we have to just accept
everything in our life and we can't get rid of bad things or bad people or toxic people in our life.
Then we are going to be more prone to diseases of those organs. So when we understand
some of the function, the general physiology of the organ, then we can understand a little bit better
and start working through some of those processes of maybe why that happened in this organ.
Maybe that's why this disease happened in this organ. Another perfect example is I think it was
Carolyn Mase that wrote a large section of one of her books, The Molecules of Emotions. I believe
in that book about how she believed it's in other people's writings as well. That breast cancer
is tied in the majority of women with breast cancer have had an emotional wound from someone they
love because you look at the purpose of the breast is to give to your baby. It's to feed and nurture
your baby. You also give your breasts sexually to your partner. So if you've been hurt by a partner
or you've been hurt by a child, you're more apt to have a disease in the breast.
Just like my previous example, if you're unable to get rid of
of waste in your life, whether it be things or whether it be toxic individuals because of
maybe a familial you've heard your mother say you shouldn't do that your whole life and you
should be nice to everybody and dare you say that this person doesn't good for you. Well,
then you're more apt to have a disease in that organ. So if you understand the physiology of that
organ, you can start asking tough questions and that's my second point. You have to start asking
yourself tough questions because it's not it's not somebody else's fault. We're not here to blame
our mother or blame a spouse, even though we might have been a victim in the situation.
Maybe you were abused by, you know, someone you loved and you were a true victim in the situation,
we don't want to relive that victimhood. Again, you're out of that situation.
We don't want to stay a victim. We want to acknowledge it and we want to say, what was nine
role in this? And maybe I was an innocent child at six years old or this took place,
but then I could, I'm not a child anymore. What's my role in moving forward out of this now?
So we want to ask ourselves tough questions in that, okay, this is what happened.
I could deal with it. I could understand my piece of this and now I know understand how I'm
choosing to move forward out of this now. If we don't make that choice to move out of this,
we're going to stay as a victim, even though it might have been a six-year-old child when it happened,
then we could never move out of that and be a victor in this situation.
Thirdly, we want to be as critical of our own behavior as others. As I said, you may have been a six-year-old
victim in this situation, but you're not six years old anymore. And when we turned 18, 20 years old,
we have to start taking that adult throw and moving on with our life. And you might have chosen to
stay in that relationship way too long, that was abusive. You may have chosen to not get rid of
that toxic waste for way too long, but it's okay. It's water under the bridge. It is what it is,
and it may have led to the situation that you're dealing with right now. But now you have to say,
where was my role in this? How do I need to change to move forward out of this? It'd be as critical
by behavior. And what I may have done in this game, that I share at least a piece of responsibility
with that. And the next one is to admit that through this, these incidents in my life, we've chosen
certain games to play. And we, whatever it is in life, we've chosen certain games to play. And
what would be example of us, you know, I'll be as straightforward and honest as possible. I'm a doctor.
Why did I choose to be a doctor? Because I had to feel like I have to, to solve everybody's problem,
is it my own messiah complex that I need to, to help other people in order to feel good about myself.
If that is true, I have to admit those things. There's some truth to that. I think there's a truth to
anybody that's helping anybody else that we have a little bit of a messiah complex. And we have to
remember that to, we serve a jealous God, and there's only one messiah. And I have to admit to that
part of the game of life that I'm playing in order for my healing to take place as well.
So we're all playing games. We all are. That's life. We have to admit to some of those games that are
destructive to others and destructive to ourselves and take responsible actions to change that.
And understand that game, that life is a game, you can choose to change the rules.
You can choose to, well, I'm not going to do that anymore. And it may change relationships
that you have that are unhealthy, that it may change relationships that you have right now that are
healthy, but as you change who you are and how you play the game of life, some people may not fully
understand you. And you have to understand that and help them work through those changes in you.
Because you don't want to just be a jerk and lose all your relationships unless
the relationship that you're losing wasn't the healthy one and you need to lose it. So understand that
you have made the rules in your game and you can change those rules. You just have to make that
decision to change those rules and have the courage to do so. And lastly, understand that it's a process.
It's not going to be easy and it's not going to be overnight.
And that's what life is. And God is forgiving and merciful God and His mercies are new every single day.
Thank goodness. And I'm going to mess up again tomorrow and I'm going to fall back into that game
that I've always played because I have that stuck in my amygdala and those those
remembrances that I have was a child that brought me to the position that I'm at right now
are not going to be easily erased. But as we look at it, we take start taking responsibility for
ourselves and we stop being the victim. And as we may have to get professional counseling and start
working through some of these things, we have to start dealing with this because there are multiple
reasons is we're digging to find the cause of your cancer. And yes, it may be a pesticide in your
larger test that caused your cancer. Why did that pesticide stay there? You have to look at that
emotional piece too. Maybe that pesticide stay there because that my emotions are stuck there. And I'm
unable to get rid of things in my life. My that would be a dogmatic position right there.
That religious position that I can't let somebody go and let things go that I can't be flexible
and that it's that I'm a bad person. If I say that that another person or another
relationship isn't healthy for me. And I need to deal with that. And you need to
may need to get counseling for that. And you may need to work through that with some people
that you love. But you have to have the courage to do so. And all I'm asking in this little video
is that you start looking at some things more critically, looking at your disease more critically,
seeing what God is trying to teach you through this because he's this is not a surprise for him.
And that that that becomes your prayer. Lord, what are you trying to teach me through this to
it's for my my best. So show me how to change. Show me what I need to change. Show me
where I haven't been bringing you the glory that I should be bringing you.
And teach me how to do that. That's what I'm asking your prayer to be. Go through these steps.
And I think you'll find them helpful. And we can talk more about this. All those emotions all your
emotions are good. It's when we get stuck in a certain situation. When we maybe for moons of our past
maybe from learned behavior that wasn't healthy, that it could cause a lot of problems. So that's
your challenge for today. And I hope that you can work through that and talk to me if you need. Thanks a
much.